وكان الوضع السياسيه في تونس يزداد تعقيدا
مع تسارع الخطى باتجاه السابع عشر من
ديسمبر موعد اجراء الانتخابات البرلمانيه
الذي تجرى فيه الانتخابات والذي تحاصره
مختلف الاتهامات الموجهه للرئيس قيس سعيد
ومسائل الخامس والعشرين من يوليو الذي
تجرى على ضوئيه هذه الانتخابات
نور الدين الامين العام للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل وهو اكبر النقابات العماليه
في تونس اعلن امام انصاره في العاصمه ان
الاتحاد لم يعد يقبل بالمسار السياسي
الراهن في تونس بسبب التفرد بالحكم
والغموض
الشعب يريد حكومه
وقال في تصريحات وصفت بانها اقوى واوضح
معارضه من اتحاد الشغل لاجراءات الرئيس
سعيد ومساره السياسي ان الانتخابات
المرتقبه بلا لون او طعم ودعا الى انقاذ
وتبقى مطالبا باصلاح القضاء ومكافحه
الفساد نحن
على الانتخابات
بلا لون وبلا تعمل
جاءت
وليده دستورا لم يكن تشاركيا ولا محل
اجمعين او موافقه الاغلبيه وصيغه على
قانون مسققه
اثبت يوما بعد يوما ما هواه من ثغرات
وخللا وهو ما نبانا اليه منذ الوهله
الاولى ولا مجيبا
وبالتاكيدا ان مسار كهذا
سيولدوا نتائج لا احد يتوقع حزم اضافه وما
يستبدله من تفكك وتفتير في هذه الاسماء
بعد خمسه احزاب معارضه هي العمال
والجمهوري والتيار الديمقراطي والتكتل
والقطب الناخبين لمقاطعه انتخابات السابعه
عشر من ديسمبر
بيانو المشترك بانها تفتقد لابسط مقاييس
النزاهه والشفافيه
والديمقراطيه وان القانون الانتخابي وضع
بشكل انفرادي كما اتهم البيان هيئه
الانتخابات بالعمل بالاوامر واحتكار كل
الصلاحيات لتنفيذ اجنده الرئيس السياسيه
الثابت ان الدستور التونسي يواجه انتقادات
متزايده من مختلف الاتجاهات السياسيه
والاجتماعيه في البلاد منذ اجازته في
يوليو الماضي بعد الاستفتاء عليه يرى فيه
كثيرون عوده للديكتاتوريه بتوسيع صلاحيات
رئيس الجمهوريه لتشمل اختصاصات تعيين
الحكومه ولا يتضمن وصفا لاقاله الرئيس
لكنه يمنح الرئيس الحق في حل البرلمان
عموما الطريق الانتخابات ال 17 من ديسمبر
التي يراد بها اسدال الستار على مسار
الخامس والعشرين من يوليو المثير للجدل
والانتقاد محفوف هو نفسه بالجدل والانتقاد
بل والتخوف من فشل ما تتمخض عنه في
التعاطي مع ازمات البلاد المتشعبه مما
يزيد من الهزات المجتمعيه الموجوده اصلا
وتهدد استقرار البلاد